ASSEMBLY ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY
AND TOXIC MATERIALS COULD. WE
ARE GOING TO PROCEED TO A ROLL
CALL BUT BEFORE WE DO THERE ARE
A FEW GROUND RULES THAT ALL
ESTABLISHED AT THE BEGINNING OF
THE MEETING. A FIRST OF ALL I'D
LIKE TO WELCOME- TO THIS
HEARING OF THE ASSEMBLY OF
ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY AND TOXIC
MATERIALS COMMITTEE I'M
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHRIS HOLDEN.
WITH DOCTOR QUIRK OUT TODAY
I'VE BEEN APPOINTED ACTING SURE
FOR THIS HEARING. I WOULD LIKE
TO START OUT BY WELCOMING
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM WHO IS.
NOT HERE YET BUT WE'RE
EXPECTING HIM SOON- WHO'S BEEN
APPOINTED TO THE THIS COMMITTEE
FOR TODAY'S HEARING. I WOULD
ALSOLIKE TO THANK ALL OF THE
STAFF THAT HAVE MADE A RETURN
TO THE CAPITAL. TO HEAR BILLS
POSSIBLE. DO THE CURRENT STAY
AT HOME ORDER WE'RE PRACTICING
PHYSICAL DISTANCE SEEN. HERE IN
THE HEARING ROOM THROUGHOUT THE
CAPITOL BUILDING. SO WE ARE
ONLY ABLE TO HAVE LIMITED
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WATCH AND
PARTICIPATE IN THE HEARING. IN
PERSON. WE HAVE A FEW DIFFERENT
OPTIONS FOR WITNESS TESTIMONY
TODAY. TODAY IN ROOM FORTY TWO
OH TWO. WE ARE HAVING A
PHYSICALLY DISTANT IN PERSON
HERE. IN THIS SPACE WE CAN ONLY
ACCOMMODATE ELEVEN PEOPLE
ELEVEN MEMBERS I SHOULD SAY A
MINIMAL CONTENDED A STAFF IN A
LIMITED NUMBER OF THE PUBLIC
AND MEDIA SO WE CAN MAINTAIN
SIX FEET. OF SPACING. THEY'RE
ALSO STRICT PHYSICAL DISTANCE
SAME PROTOCOLS FOR THE PUBLIC
TO ENTER AND LEAVE THE CAPITAL.
AND FOR THOSE HERE TODAY IN THE
HERE. IF ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY ON THE BILL PLEASE
RAISE YOUR HAND. AND I WILL ASK
YOU TO APPROACH. TIME. I WOULD
ASK THAT THE PUBLIC NOT TOUCH
THE MICROPHONE. CAN EXIT THE
HEARING ROOM ONCE YOUR DONE
TESTIFYING OR RETURN TO YOUR
SEAT. PLEASE BE SURE TO OBSERVE
PHYSICAL DISTANCE IN UPON
LEAVING THE CAPITOL INCLUDING
LIMITING ELEVATOR USE TO ONE
PERSON AT A TIME. IN ADDITION
TO BEING ABLE TO TESTIFY FROM
INSIDE THE HEARING ROOM. WE
HAVE SOME WITNESSES MAKING SO
MAKING USE OF ONE OF OUR
WITNESS VIDEO CONFERENCING
ROOMS. WHICH ARE LOCATED IN THE
CAPITAL. THOSE WITNESSES WILL
APPEAR ON THE SCREEN SO MEMBERS
CAN WATCH THEIR TESTIMONY
ALIVE. FROM OUTSIDE OF THE
HEARING ROOM AND ALSO ASK
QUESTIONS OF THESE WITNESSES.
THERE MAY BE A SLIGHT DELAY
FROM THE STREAM FROM THE
WITNESS VIDEO CONFERENCING
ROOM. SO PLEASE BE PATIENT. WE
WILL ALSO BE USING MODERATED
TELEPHONE SERVICE THROUGH WHICH
ANY WITNESS CAN TESTIFY ON A
BILL. THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR
THIS HEARING IS EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS. ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR TWO
ZERO TWO. YOU CAN ALSO FIND
THIS NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY
ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY AND TOXIC
MATERIALS COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS
WELL AS ON YOUR TV SCREEN. IF
YOUR CALL WE MEN PLEASE PLAN TO
DO SO AS THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL
YOUR TESTIFYING ON. HIS
BEGINNING THEIR BILL
PRESENTATION. THE OPERATOR ON
THE LINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN THE QUEUE BASED ON
WHETHER YOUR SUPPORT. OR OPPOSE
A BILL. IF YOU WERE CALLING IT
AN- PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE. THIS INCLUDES
MUTING YOUR LIVESTREAM
BROADCAST AND YOUR SMART
DEVICES TO REDUCE THE SOUND
DISTORTION. PLEASE ALSO BE
ADVISED THAT IF YOU ARE A MAIN
WITNESS PROVIDING TESTIMONY FOR
OR AGAINST THE BILL YOU WERE ON
THE LIVE LINE AND WE NEED TO
MEET YOURSELF UNTIL YOU ARE
CALLED ON TO SPEAK. IF YOU'RE
HAVING ANY PROBLEMS THE
MODERATED PHONE SERVICE. YOU
CAN CALL THE COMMITTEE AT. NINE
ONE SIX. THREE ONE NINE. THREE
NINE SIX FIVE IN THE COMMITTEE
STAFF WILL BE BE THERE TO TRY
TO HELP. I ALSO WANT TO NOTE
THAT WE ARE ACCEPTING WRITTEN
TESTIMONY TO THE POSITION
LETTER ALL ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. THANK YOU FOR BEARING
WITH US AS WE IMPLEMENT METHODS
TO CONTINUE TO SERVE THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA. WHILE ALSO BEING
MINDFUL RESPECTFUL OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS WE ALL
FACE. WE WILL HEAR ELEVEN BILLS
TODAY. FIVE BILLS A PROPOSED
FOR THE CONSENT CALENDAR
TESTIMONY IS LIMITED TO FOUR
MINUTES TOTAL FOR EACH SIDE.
BUDGET THIS IS PLEASE BRIEFLY
STATE YOUR NAME. POSITION AT
AFFILIATION IF ANY. I WITH THAT
ALLOWS THE COMMITTEE STAFF SO
TO PLEASE CALL THE ROLL TO
ESTABLISH A CORE. PRESENT
HOLDEN HAS FALLEN IT MELENDEZ
HERE RIGHT YEAH WE'RE RIGHT
HERE BACKING UP HERE. YEAH HERE
CRISTINA GARCIA YEAH. YOUR
HELLO. YEAH IF YOU CARE IF
YOU'RE OBERNOLTE THERE
OBERNOLTE HERE YEAH OKAY WITH
THAT ARE WITH A QUORUM BEING
ESTABLISHED OF THE CHAIR WILL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. IT'S BEEN
SECOND I WILL LAST FOR ROLL
CALL. YOU CAN CONSENT CALENDAR
IS COMPRISED OF. PRICES. EIGHTY
HI OUR AB TWENTY NINE TWENTY
OBERNOLTE. THIRTY TWO TWENTY
YES. AB THIRTY TO SIXTY ONE YES
YEAH ALL WHAT THE MOTION YOU
HAVE TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE WITH RECOMMEND
RECOMMENDATION THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. HI HOLDEN. YEAH
MELENDEZ ARE. ALL RIGHT A
REGULAR LINE THAT YEAH HI YEAH
CRISTINA GARCIA. YEAH HELLO.
NOW THIS. FIFTY FIVE NURSES
YEAH. HI OBERNOLTE I HAVE SEVEN
OF. THANK YOU THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS ADOPTED WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS TO COME TO ADD UP AND
AT SOME POINT DURING THE-
HEARING SIMILAR TO- WE'RE HERE
AT THE SMALLER WOMAN FOLLOW
ORDER. YOUR AB TWENTY EIGHT
EIGHTY TO A SCHOOL SITES
CHARTER SCHOOLS. IS BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE- IT HAS A DO PASSED
TO THE ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE AS A MOTION. YOU ARE
THE BILL YEAH OKAY IT'S BEEN
MOVED THERE'S A SECOND YOU CAN
MAKE YOUR PRESENTATION.
ABBREVIATED NUMBER AB TWENTY
EIGHTY TWO WATER REQUIRED THAT
ALL CASUAL LOCATION FOR A NEW
PRIVATE YEAH CHARTER SCHOOL OF
BE PROPERLY EVALUATED AS HIS
SAME STANDER OF HEALTH WE HAVE
ESTABLISH FULL PUBLIC SCHOOL
AND CURRENT BE AT THE CURRENT
LAW DOES NOT REQUIRE PRIVATE
SCHOOL AND CHARTER SCHOOL NEED
INSIDE REQUIREMENTS S. SAFETY
ASSESSMENT AS SCHOOL BEFORE
SHOOTING AND SCHOOL SO CALLED.
OUT TO PRIVAT ENTRADAS HAVE
BILL IN THE REAL AND SAY TO LOW.
THERE'S ONE IN MY DISTRICT AND-
THAT'S PART THE ALL TRY AND
COME OF THE SAFETY TO STEW AND-
THE PEOPLE WHO THE WORKER IT SO
IT IS SASH. THAT ALL POTENTIAL
SCHOOL SITE. OFTEN EVEN. IN
ORDER TO PROTECT THE WILL BEING
OF ALL THE STUDENTS AND THE
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES. TODAY I HAVE-
ALLEN ABS WAS THE BAY AREA AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT.
WHO IS THE SPONSOR OF THE BILL
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. SOLO
ASKED THE MODERATOR PLEASE-
CONNECT ELLEN TO THE HEARING.
ALAN. WAS RATHER IT OR IF YOU
COULD- OPEN LINE FOR WITH THIS
IN SUPPORT- THIS WOULD BE-
ALLEN APPS. BUT CURRENTLY
CONNECTED TO THE CONFERENCE AS
A CO HOST. ALAN ABBAS IF YOU
ARE ON THE PHONE LINES PLEASE
PRESS STAR ZERO SON OPERATOR
CAN RETRIEVE YOUR LINE. HELLO
I'M IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM IN.
THIS OKAY GOOD MORNING I CHAIR
HOLDEN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- MY NAME IS ALAN APPS
ON THE LEGISLATIVE OFFICER WITH
THE BAY AREA AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT WHICH IS TO
PROVIDE A HEALTHIER ENVIRONMENT
TO NEARLY EIGHT NO NINE COUNTY
AREA GEN AREA EIGHTY ONE. AB
TWENTY EIGHT THE TO AND WE
THANK YOU MEMBER TO FOR. THE
IMPORTANT BUILT PROTECT
CHILDREN HEALTH. IN LAW PRIOR
TO CONSTRUCTING A NEW PUBLIC
SCHOOL OR PUBLICLY FUNDED
CHARTER SCHOOL SCHOOL
AUTHORITIES ARE REQUIRED TO
PERFORM SEVERAL ACTS OF DUE
DILIGENCE TO BETTER ENSURE THE
HEALTH OF THEIR FUTURE STUDENTS
AND SCHOOL STAFF. THEY
DETERMINE THAT THE PROPERTY TO
BE BUILT UPON IS NOT A CURRENT
OR FORMER HAZARDOUS WASTE SITE
OR HAZARDOUS SUBSTANCE RELEASE.
AND THEY CONSULT WITH STATE AND
LOCAL AGENCIES OF FINDING THAT
THE HEALTH RISKS OR OTHER
POLLUTION SOURCES DO NOT AND
WILL NOT CONSTITUTE. AN TOOL OR
POTENTIAL ENGAGEMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH PERSONS. WHO WOULD
ATTEND OR BE EMPLOYED THE
SCHOOL. THIS INCLUDES WORKING.
LUCIEN WELL DISTRICT. THE MAN.
IDENTIFIED BOTH. AND I'M
PERMITS FACILITY. WITHIN THAT
DISTRICTS AT THE PARTY
INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED TO
FREEWAYS AN OPERA BUSY TRAFFIC
CORRIDORS. LARGE AGRICULTURAL
OPERATIONS. OF RAIL YARDS- AND
OTHER OUT A MISSION SOURCES
WITHIN ONE QUARTER OF A MILE
THE PROPOSED SCHOOL SITE. THIS
IS A REQUIREMENT THAT DOES NOT
CURRENTLY A PRIVATE SCHOOLS AND
SOME CHARTER SCHOOLS AND WHILE
WE ARE NOT CLAIMING THAT A
LARGE NUMBER OF THESE SCHOOLS
ARE POORLY CITED IN PLANET
DENSITY REPURPOSE INFILL SITES
REYES THE POP OD THAT WITHOUT.%
DUE DILIGENCE FUTURE GOALS MAY
BE ACTED IN THE VICINITY OF
POLLUTION SOURCES THAT
UNNECESSARILY EXPOSE CHILDREN
IN SCHOOL SO USING CREATE AN
UNHEALTHY WORK INVITE. THE
TWENTY EIGHT TWO REQUIRES THESE
LOW THIRTIES TO ASSESS. WASTE
IN A POLLUTION CAN DO ON IN IN
THE FACILITY IF THE SANITY OF
PROPOSED SCHOOL TO A KNOWLEDGE
THIS INFORMATION AND IF
NECESSARY TO USE IT IN THEIR
DECISION MAKING PROCESS WHEN
CONSTRUCTING THEIR SCHOOL. WE
WANT TO AVOID SITUATIONS WHERE
PARENTS BRING THERE'S THEIR
CHILD. TO THE FIRST DAY OF
SCHOOL ONLY TO QUESTION WHETHER
THE CHILD HAVE A HEALTHY
LEARNING IN. ON BEHALF BAY AREA
MANAGE DISTRICT I THANK YOU.
MEMBER CHIU FOR OFFERING BILL
AND I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WE
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY OF WE
WILL TURN TO OUR PHONE
MODERATOR TO SEE IF WE HAVE
ANY- WITNESSES TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY EIGHT
EIGHTY TWO THESE WILL BE.
WITNESSES WHO WILL GIVE THEIR
NAPA. AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
TO SHOW SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN IT TO
ZERO AND THE OPERATOR WILL GIVE
YOUR LINE NUMBER AND FURTHER
INSTRUCTIONS. IF YOU'RE USING A
SPEAKER PHONE PLEASE PICK UP
AND STEP BEFORE PRESSING THE
NUMBERS. AND WE'RE GOING TO
LINE NUMBER THIRTY LINE THREE
ZERO PLEASE PROCEED YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING BRAMBLE
HERE SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NEXT WE
ALIGN THIRTY THREE THREE THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MISTER CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS RON
REYNOLDS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PRIVATE SCHOOL ORGANIZATIONS IN
SUPPORT. NO ONE FURTHER IN THE
QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE THANK YOU
A WE HAVE NO PRIMARY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION SO WILL LAST THE
PHONE MODERATOR IF THERE IS
ANYONE ONLINE- TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY EIGHT
EIGHTY TWO. JOHN ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU OPPOSE THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. THERE IS NO ONE IN Q. IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE CONTINUE
THANK YOU WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE TO SEE IF THERE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. SOME
AMERICAN RESEARCHING Q. MESSAGE
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD I WAS JUST CURIOUS-
SINCE IT INVOLVES CHARTER
SCHOOLS WHAT IS THE- POSITION
OF THE FURNITURE. SO CATION AS
FAR AS YOU KNOW WALMART. YEAH
FOR A OPPOSITION LETTERS THE
ANY ANY INPUT FROM THEM- IRWIN
NO NOT NOT AT ALL THIS IS AGAIN
TO PROTECT YOUR EMPLOYEE US
WELL AND TO- GROUP TO REALLY OF
AVOIDING ANY OUTCRY AFTER DAY
OPEN UP YOUR SCHOOL YEAH NO I
SUPPORT THE BILL BUT I WAS JUST
CURIOUS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THE OTHER MEMBERS WOULD LIKE A
QUESTION HERE NINETY NINE- SO
EMERGE YOU IF YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
WILL RECOVER MUCH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE OKAY THIS BILL HAS A DO
PASSED MOTION. OF TWO OF THE
APPROPRIATIONS IT IS A MOTION A
SECOND ROLL CALL PLEASE. AB TWO
EIGHT EIGHT TWO. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
HOLDEN HI HOLDEN I MELENDEZ.
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA HI.
BAUER-KAHAN PARA QUE HAN HI
CRISTINA GARCIA CRISTINA GARCIA
I BLOOM. MATHIS MURATSUCHI HI.
C. GI OBERNOLTE. NOT VOTING
OBERNOLTE NOT VOTING. THAT
MEASURE HAS FIVE THAT'S ROGERS
ALBUM WE THE ROLE OPEN FOR UP
TO MEMBERS MEMBERS TO OUT ON
MAKING US FEEL LIKE YOU'RE
ACTUALLY SINCE I WILL NOW TURN
TO- ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA 2%
ON A. B. NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE.
OF THE MINUTE PRODUCTS
INGREDIENT DISCLOSURE. THIS
GOAL. AS A ENJOY THE DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU. OF COURSE I WANTED THEN
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR WORK
ON THIS MEASURE AND I GLADLY
ACCEPT ALL OF THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENT A FLAT LINE ON PAGE
SEVEN EIGHT NINE AND TEN OF THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS. AB NINETEEN
EIGHTY NINE WILL TAKE PEOPLE'S
HEALTH BY REQUIRING THE
DISCLOSURE OF ALL INGREDIENTS
IN MISTER PRODUCTS. INCLUDING
TAMPONS PADS CLUBS. THIS
SPONGES AND MITCHELL UNDERWEAR.
MICHAEL AT TH LEGISLATION INTO
IS TO INCREASE THE AWARENESS OF
TOXIC CHEMICALS CARLY AND I
MISS FOR PRODUCTS. THERE IS
THERE NOT A LUXURY AND PEOPLE
SHOULD HAVE DOLLARS TO KNOW ALL
WITHIN THEIR PRODUCTS ARE USING
FOR ABOUT FORTY YEARS OF THEIR
LIFE AND MAKES THE FIRST CHOICE.
I WOULD LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
OPPOSITE IN MY OFFICE. AND MY
OFFICE HAS BEEN WORKING WITH
THIS THERE'S ON THIS BILL AND
WE BELIEVE THE COMMITTEE I
MESSAGE REFLECTIVE OF THAT.
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION- ON THE REMAINING
CONTENTS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU WE
HAVE ONE TO ONE WITNESS IN
SUPPORT TESTIFYING BY PHONE-
PHONE MODERATOR IS CRISTINA
HILDEBRAND. WITH A VOICE FOR
SHORT ADVOCACY ISSUES ONLINE
SHE MAY PERCY. HI THIS IS
CHRISTINA HEALTH RENT CAN YOU
HEAR ME THIS. RIGHT I THANK YOU
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR HEARING EIGHTY
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE MY NAME'S
KRISTINA HELD A BRAND THAT I AM
THE FOUNDER AND PRESIDENT
PEOPLE LIKE YOU TRY TOPIC THE
OUR MISSION IS TO ADVOCATE
PEOPLE'S RIGHT TO BE FULLY
INFORMED ABOUT COMPOSITION
QUALITY SHORT AND LONG TERM
HEALTH EFFECTS OF ALL PRODUCTS.
AND BY PEOPLE'S BODIES SUCH AS
FOOD AT WATER PHARMACEUTICALS
COSMETICS AND IN THIS CASE
MENTAL PRODUCT. WHEN
ORGANIZATION FOR THAT AMOUNT
FOR PRODUCT LABELING BILL WOULD
OFTEN NEW YORK LAST YEAR WE
KNEW THAT THE BILL WAS WHAT WE
WANTED TO. WITHIN CALIFORNIA
THIS YEAR WE'RE THANKFUL TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA FRIEND
TO DO THINK EIGHTY NINETEEN
EIGHTY NINE THE MENSTRUAL
PRODUCT RIGHT TO KNOW ACT OF
TWENTY TWENTY. AB NINETEEN
EIGHTY NINE YOUR REQUIRES
MENSTRUAL PRODUCT.
MANUFACTURERS TO. YEAH IN THEIR
PRODUCT AND THAT. CHECK INTO.
WE BELIEVE THAT IT LIKELY AMPLE
TO PROVIDE CAN. NEXT AND- OR-
THE- BUT IT CAN IN THEM THE
PRODUCT. SO THAT THEY CAN MAKE
EDUCATE CHOICE ON WHICH PRODUCT
HELPFUL OR HUMP TO THEM AND
THEIR FAMILIES. BECAUSE THEY'RE
CONSIDERED MEDICAL DEVICES THIS
IS NOT REQUIRED AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL. MENTAL PRODUCT
MANUFACTURERS CURRENTLY LABEL
THAT PRODUCT TO VARYING
DEGREES. BUT NONE ARE ALL
INCLUSIVE. WE BELIEVE THAT AB
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE WE'LL
DO THAT. STUDIES HAVE SHOWN
THAT SOME MENSTRUAL PRODUCTS
CONTAIN INGREDIENTS. SUCH A
PARABEN BY LATE AND BUT WHEN
ALL. AMONG MANY OTHERS WHICH
HAVE BEEN FOUND TO BE HARMFUL
TO HUMAN HEALTH. MENTAL PRODUCT
OFTEN ASSEMBLED PRODUCT. AND
WITH THIS COMMITTEES AMENDMENT
AB NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE THE
ROBOT BILL THAT WILL ENSURE ALL
INGREDIENTS THAT. A TECHNICAL-
FUNCTIONAL. LISTED IN THE
PACKAGING. INCLUDING GRADIENTS
THAT ARE CONSIDERED
CONFIDENTIAL BUSINESS
INFORMATION. THANKS IT ON ANY
OF THE. TWENTY ONE OR TARGETED
LIST THAT. EXIT HAS THE TO TRY.
AND OR AN ANTI. OR TALK ABOUT
AND- I THINK IN BY THE UNITED
STATES AND BY. PROTECTION A-
THE FEDERAL AGENCY FOR TOXIC
SUBSTANCES AND DISEASE REGISTRY
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AT THE
EUROPEAN UNION CANADA THE
INTERNATIONAL AGENCY ON CANCER
RESEARCH AMONG OTHERS. THESE
LOOK FOR THE SAME WAY OTHER
THAN THE ONE WHICH IS
SPECIFICALLY DETECTION FACE AS
IN AT. TWO FIFTY EIGHT THE
CLEANING PRODUCTS RIGHT NOW ACT
UP IN TWO THOUSAND AND
SEVENTEEN WHICH IS CONSIDERED
THE GOLD STANDARD AMAZING
PRODUCTS IN CALIFORNIA. WHILE
YOU WILL HEAR OPPOSITION
HAPPENED TODAY THOSE THE
CLOTHES ARE IN AGREEMENT THAT
MENSTRUAL PRODUCTS SHOULD BE
LABELED IN FACT BY MUCH SAYS
THAT THE WOMEN FOR THAT THE US
WITH THE SPONSOR OF THE NEW
YORK MENTAL PRODUCT DISCLOSURE
BILL. HOWEVER THEY WILL SHARE
THAT THEY FEEL THAT AB NINETEEN
EIGHTY NINE DID NOT GO FAR
ENOUGH AND SHOULD MERIT THE NEW
YORK LANGUAGE THEY HAVE TO. BUT
THEY MAY BE INGREDIENTS NOT ON
THE TWENTY ONE LIKE THAT ARE IN
TRADE SECRET AND APPLE WOULD
NOT BE DISCLOSED. AVOID PATRYK
THAT MAKES THE AND THE METRO
PRODUCT MANUFACTURERS FIELD BUT
IN FACT AB NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE
GUYS BUT THEN THE NEW YORK LAW
NO. I PLEDGE COUNCIL HAS A FINE
AND THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
INDICATE THE NEW YORK LANGUAGES
TENSIONING UNCONSTITUTIONAL. IF
CONDUCTED CONFIDENTIAL BUSINESS
INFORMATION IS REQUIRED TO BE
DISCLOSED WE KNOW THAT
MANUFACTURERS DO NOT CREATE
STATE. PACKAGES THERE IF THE
CALIFORNIA LANGUAGES ARE THE
MORE STRINGENT LANGUAGE BEHOLD
WHICHEVER DOCKET. WE ALSO KNOW
THAT ONE CAN YOU MAKE THE CALL
WHERE AGAIN GRADIENT THERE AND
DIMOND. BOTH TRIED DISCLOSURE.
EVERY WOMAN IS SOME FORM OF
MENSTRUAL. ONCE A MONTH BUT-
TWO YEARS BUT THERE LIFE. EACH
AND- OF THEM THAT KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE PUT IN OR ON THE BODY
AND THE TO BE ABLE TO. AN IN
CHOI. WELL WE WOULD LIKE THIS
BILL SUPPORT MANUFACTURES TO.
BY EVERY SINGLE INGREDIENT OUR
OPINION IS THAT IT IS BETTER TO
HAVE AS MUCH DISCLOSURE AND
LEAKING POSSIBLE THIS YEAR.
THAN NONE AT ALL. WE RESPECT
THE OFF YOUR- I. DATE BUT THAT
CALIFORNIA NAY QUALITY NEW YORK
THE COMPLEMENT HATE THAT THIS
BILL IF DIGITAL AND MORE FOR
MANUFACTURERS TO WORK BUCKLEY
NAY. ALMOST UP TO ALLOW WOMEN
MAINTENANCE CHOI NATIONWIDE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR ACT MIGHT
HAPPEN. THANK YOU WE APPRECIATE
YOUR TESTIMONY. BOB WE WILL NOW
TURN TO OUR. PHONE MODERATOR
TO. THE WHETHER OR NOT WE HAVE
AND- OF A- NINETEEN A NINE A-
OF THESE WILL BE WITNESSES THAT
WILL GIVE THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION. AND POSITION. IF
YOU LIKE TO MAKE YOUR VOICE
HEARD IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
YOU HAVE A FEW WITNESSES THAT
ARE QUEUING UP PLEASE ALLOW
MOMENT FOR US TO PROVIDE THEM
THEIR LINE NUMBERS. OKAY WE'LL
GO TO START WITH THE LINE FORTY
THAT SLIME FOUR ZERO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BY FORTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I YES I MY NAME IS
KIMBERLY HOW I REPRESENT THE
LUCAS COMMUNITIES SPECIFICALLY
WITH THE TOP ON THE SAME AND I
DO APPROVED AND. EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU WILL GO TO LINE
TWENTY TWO TWO TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS BECKY
WOOLWICH ARE NOT AFFILIATED
WITH ANY. ORGANIZATION BUT I AM
A MEMBER OF. IN A DAY
POPULATION AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU YOU ALL NOW
GLOBAL LINE UP TO THIRTY FOUR
THREE. HI GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS SUSAN PUBLIC AND I AM AN RN.
THE MIDWIFE. AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL I DO BELIEVE IN THE
PRECAUTIONARY PRINCIPLE I LEFT
GOVERNMENT RIGHT KEEP OUR- JUST
NAME AFFILIATION AND POSITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND THAT
IS EXHAUSTED THE QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE. IT'S BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED- LET ME JUST NOTE THAT
WE HAVE ONE WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION TO TESTIFY BY PHONE
AND ONE BY A WITNESS VIDEO
CONFERENCING ROOM- WE WILL LOOK
TO. ALEXANDRIA SCRUTTON WITH
WOMEN'S VOICES FOR THE EARTH
YOU MEMBERS PROCEED WITH YOUR
TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
DISTINGUISHED MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- ALEXANDER SCRANTON
DIRECTOR OF SCIENCE AND
RESEARCH WTH WOMEN'S WHICH IS
FOR THE- A WOMEN'S
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION WITH THOUSANDS OF
MEMBERS IN CALIFORNIA WE STAND
OPPOSED TO EIGHTY NINETEEN
EIGHTY NINE UNLESS AMENDED.
WHIMS WHICH TO THE EARTH WAS A
CO SPONSOR ABOUT THE TWO FIVE
EIGHT THE LAW THIS LEGISLATION
IS MODELED AFTER SB TWO FIVE
EIGHT IS NOT A ONE SIZE FITS
ALL ADULT OTHER PRODUCT
SECTORS. GOOD STARTING. NINE
FORMULA IS NOT ABOUT PROP. BE
AMENDED. IS RECOMMENDING AND A
DISH MEMBERS PROPOSED SOMEONE
GARCIA OR GO START. BUT
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS ARE NEEDED
GET THE NEEDED LAW OF ANGER
DISCLOSURE. SPECIFICALLY THE
BILL SHOULD BE AMENDED TO
INCLUDE ALLERGENS FOUND IN
NATURAL PRODUCTS BUT ARE NOT ON
ANY OF THE DESIGNATED LAST.
ALLERGENS LIKE A SHINING A
NATION OF MC AND MINE AND
ACCOLADES WHICH ARE TRUE
CONCERNS. WE KNOW THAT MANY
USERS OF METROPARKS EXPIRY
ADVERSE EFFECTS SUCH AS
RACCOONS AND ALLERGIC REACTIONS
EVERY. OLDER FOR EACH PREVENT
USERS AND NEW THEY WERE BEING.
TO AND COULD AVOID ARE ALRP. WE
ALSO RECOMMEND LOWERING THE
THRESHOLD OF PRINCE ALLERGEN
DISCLOSURE FROM HUNDRED PARTS
PER MILLION TO TEN PARTS PER
MILLION AND TO ELIMINATE THE
THRESHOLD ALL TO GET THERE FOR
ANY FREIGHTERS ANGRY. IT
DOESN'T LAST. FRAGRANCE
COMPETITION MAY INCLUDE COMING
INTO CANCER REPRODUCTIVE HARM
INFERTILITY AND BIRTH DEFECTS.
I KNOW BUT IT ONLY REQUIRES
FRAGRANT SCOTIA BRING GRADIENTS
ABOVE A HUNDRED. I CONSIDER
THE- ARE YOU SOME OF THE- AND
OVER TISSUE THERE'S BE NO. AND
SB TWO FIVE EIGHT ANY
INGREDIENT ON ONE OF THE
DESIGNATED LIST IT'S REQUIRED
TO BE DISCLOSED NO MATTER THE
LEVEL OF THE PRODUCT INCLUDING
AND FRAGRANCE. THE LEVEL OF
DISCLOSURE FOR FRAGRANCE
ALLERGENS SHIP IN PARTS PER
MILLION AS REQUIRED IN YOUR
OPINION FOR LEAVE ON COSMETIC.
BUT HE CANNOT BE MET FOR
ADVOCATING FOR THE BILL WOULD
COME VERY CLOSE PROVIDING THE
CRITICAL INFORMATION METATRADER
SHOULD HAPPEN WHEN THEY
PURCHASE THESE PRODUCTS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK NOW WE
HAVE OF FOR THE WITNESS VIDEO
CONFERENCING ROOM LARISSA
SUSPICIOUS WITH BABY PRODUCTS
ASSOCIATION YOU MAY PROCEED
WITH YOUR TESTIMONY. THANK YOU
AT GOOD MORNING HI EVERYBODY
I'LL LYRICIST ASPEN IS HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE- BABY AN ADULT
HYGIENE PRODUCTS ASSOCIATION
OUT FIRST I WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING FOR AT PUBLIC
TESTIMONY REMOTELY I ALSO WANT
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF
THE AUTHOR STAFF ALL THE STATE
WILL INVOLVED. IN THIS SPELL
OUT THE ACCEPTANCE OF THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS- THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HAS AGREED TO
WE ARE IMPROVING OUR OP DISHING
THE BILL- AND WE ARE IN. WITH
THE CONTINUE DISCUSSION THAT
WE'VE HAD WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS
THIS. WE I WANT TO IT A LINE
ALL OF OUR CONCERNS WITH
EVERYBODY THAT'S TESTIFIED SO
FAR OUT OUR PRIMARY CONCERN IS
ENSURING THAT CONSUMERS HAVE
CLEAR ACCURATE AND MEANINGFUL-
DISCLOSURES WHEN PURCHASING
MENSTRUAL PRODUCTS. WE THINK
THAT THE MEN COMMIT AMENDMENTS
I ALLOW FOR ADDITIONAL CLARITY
TO ENSURE THAT OUR CONSUMERS
ARE ABLE TO CAN. ACCURATELY
COMPARE PRODUCTS WE MANUFACTURE
FIRST- WE REMAIN COMMITTED TO
ONGOING THIS DISC AND AT AND TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT
MAY BE RAISED BY THE OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS AND- WE ACTUALLY
ENCOURAGE THAT THIS BILL MOVE
FOR IT SO THAT. THAT DOES THAT
AND I THINK FOR YOUR TIME. FOR
THE MONEY. UHHUH STRONG
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES ONLINE. IF YOU'D LIKE
TO VOICE OPPOSITION YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THE TIME
WE'VE GOT A LINE MEMBERS THIRTY
EIGHT THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. JANUARY TERRACE ON BEHALF
OF THE CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE A SUPPORT IF
AMENDED POSITION CURRENTLY ON
THE BILL BELOW. TO ENGAGE IN
MOVING FORWARD THANK. YOU WE'LL
GO TO LINE NUMBER THIRTY SIX
THREE SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING HARING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ADAM REGULARLY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
ONE ECHO THE COMMENTS MADE BY
LARISSA CENTER FOR BABY AND ALL
HOW YOU PRODUCT. WITH THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. YOUR
POSITION TO A NEUTRAL THANK YOU
THANK YOU. LOCAL LINE NUMBER
EIGHTEEN THAT'S ONE EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO THIS IS
NICOLE CAN UNITS ON BEHALF OF
THE FRAGRANCE CREATORS
ASSOCIATION AND WE ALSO ARE
OFFICIALLY REMOVING OUR
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL WITH HE
AMENDMENTS BEING TAKEN ON THAT
THAT WE ARE A TO CONTINUING
STATE COURT CONVERSATION- WHAT
THE AUTHOR THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NO MORE IN Q. YOU MAY PROCEED
THANK YOU WILL RECOGNIZE OF
THOSE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
WHO WERE HERE IN THE COMMITTEE
HEARING ROOM AGAIN NAME.
AFFILIATION AND YOUR POSITION-
GREAT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS DON CAP CAME WITH ME Q.
CAN'T CAN'T ASSOCIATES ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION. WE PREACH OF THE
AUTHOR WORKING WITH THE
INDUSTRY- AND ARE PLEASED TO
REMOVE OUR POSITION- WITH THE
AMENDMENTS TAKEN AND ARE NOW
NEUTRAL THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
HOW WE WOULD BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE AND SEE IF ANY
MEMBERS HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. SEEING NINE HEARING
NONE. OF THIS GARCIA YOU CAN
CLOSE. THIS ONE I THINK
EVERYONE HAS BEEN WORKING ON
THIS ONE WORDS ONCE AGAIN AND
WILL CONTINUE WORKING WITH. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. OKAY THERE'S BEEN A
MOTION MADE ITS DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS ROLL CALL PLEASE.
AB NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE
CRISTINA GARCIA MOTION DO PASS
AS AMENDED TO THE ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE HOLDEN
HI HOLDEN I. MELENDEZ ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA HI THERE CAN. WHERE
CAN I CRISTINA GARCIA I
CRISTINA GARCIA I. BLOOM BLOOM
I MATHIS. MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI
I OBERNOLTE. OBERNOLTE NOT
VOTING. THE MEASURE HAS SIX
THAT'S- THE BILL IS OUT OF
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
YOUR GOOD WORK THERE AND WE
WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS TO OUT ON- IF I
COULD LET US GO BACK TO THE
CONSENT- CAL- THERE IS A
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTY AND WE
NEED TO AND EXACTLY I THINK WAS
JUST WAITING FOR MR TO GET HER
BUT- ANYWAY. SO HAVE TO. GO
BACK THROUGH THAT ASSIST SO IF
THERE'S A MOTION TO ADOPT THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. SECOND BEEN
MOVED AND SECONDED ROLL CALL
PLEASE. THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS
COMPRISED OF AB TWENTY FIVE
SIXTY QUIRK AB TWENTY EIGHT
FORTY NINE CHAO AB TWENTY NINE
TWENTY OBERNOLTE AB THIRTY TWO
TWENTY E. S. T. M. A. B. THIRTY
TO SIXTY ONE HERE'S- WHAT THE
MOTION TO PASS. RATIONS
COMMITTEE RECOMMENDATION THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. HOLDEN HI
HOLDEN AYE MELENDEZ. ARAMBULA I
CAN I CAN I CRISTINA GARCIA
CRISTINA GARCIA I BLOOM. BLOOM
HI MATT THIS MURATSUCHI
MURATSUCHI I OBERNOLTE
O'DONNELL TI. THE MEASURE HAS
SIX THANK YOU THEM THE-
CONSPICUOUS AS ADOPTED AND WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR MEMBERS
TO OUT ON- NOW WE HAVE THE
PLEASURE OF HEARING ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY TWO NINETY SIX OUR
WORK AND IT'S GOING TO BE
PRESENTED BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BARK A HAND AND THIS YOU WILL
ALSO BE PRESENTED ON THIS.
OTHER VEHICLE AB TWENTY TWO
THIRTY THREE WILL MOVE FORWARD
WITH. TWENTY TWO NINETY SIX.
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND- I'M HERE
TO PRESENT AB TWENTY TWO NINETY
SIX ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER QUIRK. AB TWENTY TWO
NINETY SIX ALLOWS COUNTIES WITH
LOCAL OVERSIGHT OF SMALL
DRINKING WATER SYSTEMS TO ELECT
TO PARTICIPATE IN A FUNDING
STABILIZATION PROGRAM
ADMINISTERED BY THE STATE WATER
BOARD. WITHOUT FURTHER DO I
WANT TO TURN IT OVER TO OUR
FIRST WITNESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL.
RIGHT WILL MOVE TO OUR PRIMARY
WITNESS IN SUPPORT. TESTIFYING
BY PHONE DOCTOR QUIRK YOU MAY
PROCEED WITH YOUR TESTIMONY.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAUER K. HAND
FOR PRETENDING AB TWENTY TWO
NINETY SIX ON MY BEHALF. AB
TWENTY TWO NINETY SIX PROVIDE
CRITICAL FUNDING STABILIZATION
TO SMALL DRINKING WATER SYSTEMS
WITH LOCAL OVERSIGHT CURRENTLY
AT RISK OF. WE MADE OVERSIGHT
BACK TO STAY SO WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO HERE IS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE LOCALS IN TROUBLE
OF OVERSIGHT THE STATE. YEAH
WELL THE RESEARCHERS COULD
BOARD DOES. HAVE ANY INTEREST
IN TAKING THAT OVER- THE ACCESS
TO SAFE CLEAN AND AFFORDABLE
WATER HAS NEVER BEEN MORE
CRITICAL HOWEVER CURRENT PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS IS PUT EVEN MORE
THE FINANCIAL STRAIN ON LOCAL
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH RESOURCES.
THIS BILL WILL ALLOW COUNTIES
WITH LOCAL OVERSIGHT TO OPT
INTO A FUNDED STABILIZATION
PROGRAM BASED ON THE
DETERMINATION OF NEED SO THAT
THEY CAN CONTINUE TO SEARCH
SMALL DRINKING WATER SYSTEM. WE
THOSE SERVE RURAL INDEED.
COMMUNITIES THANK YOU I
RESPECTFULLY ASK DERIVED OUT.
THANK YOU DOCTOR QUIRK I WILL
NOW MOVE TO THE WITNESSES
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
YOUR BILL- JUSTIN ALONG WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
ADMINISTRATORS- YOU MAY PROCEED
WITH YOUR TESTIMONY. PHONE
MODERATOR IS JUST IN MILAN ON
THE LINE. IS THE PHONE
MODERATOR ON THE LINE. YES
SORRY MR ROLE ON DECIDED TO
SELF MUTE I'M GOING TO ON MUTE
HIM ONE MOMENT. A LINE IS NOW
OPEN. THANK YOU GOOD LUCK NEW
NINE CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THIS IS JUST MIND WITH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
ADMINISTRATIVE THE SPONSORS OF
THE BILL BUT ACTED THANK DOCTOR
QUIRK IN HIS COMMITTEE AS WELL
WORKING WITH THAT. ALL RIGHT
THERE'S TWO CREDIT CORRECT
READY AT THIS BILL WOULD HURT
IN THIS COMMITTEE LOST YEAH AND
AS DOCTOR MAIN AND IT'S MORE
URGENT THAN EVER. AT THE INTENT
OF THE DAILY SHOW LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS ACT. BY THE SIDE
WHO THE IMPORT. RIGHT THANK YOU
FOR AGENCIES. AND SMALL SYSTEMS.
THE WILL PREPARE THAT TO PAY
AND HE I WOULD BE. CLOSELY WITH
THE STATE WATER. CONTROL BOARD
ON THIS AND I REALLY THAT
EVERYBODY RECOGNIZES THERE'S A
NEED TO CONTINUE THE STABILITY
OF THE LOCALS TO PROVIDE THAT
OVERSIGHT THAT PROVIDE A
CRITICAL SERVICE TO THE SMALL
WATER SYSTEMS. AND TO THE
COMMUNITY THAT THEY SERVE. I
WANT GO THROUGH MY NAY FAULT
WHICH OUTLINES THE DETAILED.
BUT THE KEEP. IT'S OPTIONAL PRO.
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS MAY ELECT
HERE'S THIS ALTERNATIVE FUNDING
SOURCE FOR. IT CAN BE NO. WE
START RIGHT UP IN LAW YEAR AND
SIMILAR. FROM THE WATER A-
THERE COME AROUND A BRICK. THE
VALUE AND WE THE COMMON THE
NUMBER OF THEIR CONCERN. THIRTY
THIS EXTENSIVE SUPPORT SEE
SECTOR HEALTH OFFICES RC RC WHO
YOU'LL HEAR FROM AND YOU MISS
INDIVIDUAL JURISDICTIONS
INCLUDING PUTTING YOUR- SO CALL
CENTER COSTA COUNTY SISKIYOU.
AND OTHERS EVEN THE CITY OF
BERKLEY ALL ON BOARD SO WE
HOPE. YOU CONSIDER JUST THERE.
AND PERHAPS DEAL WITH YOUR
FIRST PROVISION THAT WE
UNDERSTOOD ALSO THAT WE OUT
THIS BILL THE COST PRETTY BE
GRAY TO THE OF CALIFORNIA AGAIN
THANK YOU FOR ACCOMMODATING US.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE
AS THIS MOVES FORWARD. THANK
YOU I APPRECIATE YOUR
TESTIMONY- OUR NECKS PRIMARY
WITNESS WILL BE MARIANNA WARMER
DOWN WITH LITTLE COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
YOU MAY PROCEED. PHONE
MODERATOR ARE YOU ATTEMPTING TO
GET MERION WARMER DOWN. ON THE
LINE. SHE'S NOT LISTED ON THE
AUDIO. ALL RIGHT WELL THEN
WE'LL PROCEED TO- ANY WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY TWO
NINETY SIX AGAIN THOSE WOULD BE
WITNESSES PRESENTING JUST THEIR
NAME. THEIR AFFILIATION AND
THEIR SUPPORT. FOR THOSE OF.
OKAY. COLLABORATOR ONCE. AGAIN
ON THE PHONE IF YOU'D LIKE TO
VOICE SUPPORT PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. THERE'S NO
ONE SHOWING UP AT THIS TIME.
OKAY WE HAVE NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION PHONE
MODERATOR DO YOU HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY TWO NINETY SIX.
WITNESSES FROM OPPOSITION YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME
YOUR UP ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
THANK YOU LINE THIRTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. RIGHT YEAH MY
APOLOGIES MY NAME IS MARYANN
WARMER DAM I'M WITH RC RC GOOD
AFTERNOON KEREN MEMBERS JUST
WANT TO REITERATE SOME OF WHAT
MR MY MINE HAD ARTICULATED THAT
MANY OF OUR MEMBER COUNTIES ARE
SMALL INSERT ECONOMICALLY
DISTRESSED POPULATIONS. TWENTY
TWO. CABLE REMEMBER COUNTIES TO
OVERSEE THEIR WATER SYSTEM
THROUGH LTA DON'T DELEGATION
AGREEMENT. AS REQUIRED BY BOTH
STATE AND FEDERAL LAW WITH A
MORE EFFICIENT USE OF LIMITED
RESOURCES. AB TWENTY TWO NINETY
SIX DOES PROVIDE AN OPT IN
OPTIONAL ALTERNATIVE FUNDING
MECHANISM WHICH ALLOWS COUNTIES
TO MAKE THE DECISION THAT BEST
REFLECTS THE COMMUNITIES NEEDS
WHILE MAINTAINING CAPACITY TO
ADDRESS THE PORTFOLIO
CONTINUITIES IN THIS AREA. FOR
THESE REASONS WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY TWO NINETY
SIX THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NO
ONE ELSE PICK YOU UP AT THIS
TIME. OKAY SO WE HAVE- WILL
TURN TO. THE COMMITTEE IF THE
COMMITTEE HAS ANY QUESTIONS.
YES SIR OBERNOLTE I THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR SO A CEMEX
CONCERNS THAT I HAVE ABOUT THIS
BILL IS THAT IF A LOCAL PRIMACY
AGENCY. DELEGATES IT'S VIA
FORTY TO THE STATE WATER BOARD
I WITH THAT RESULT POTENTIALLY
HIGHER FEES IN SOME AREAS
BECAUSE THE WHOLE REASON FOR
DAHLE JUSTIFICATION FOR THE
BILL IS THAT NOT A FUNDING IS
AVAILABLE SO MY QUESTION IS. IF
WE'RE GOING TO STEER MORE
FUNDING TO THESE RURAL COUNTY
IS. THAT COMING FROM. DR DO YOU
AN ANSWER. LET'S HEAR FROM OUR
WITNESSES MISTER MALONE. YES
THEY ARE. DOCTOR QUIRK ARE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF IN ALL I CAN
ADDRESS THAT YOU HEAR. WITH HER
PLEASE PROCEED OKAY THANK YOU
THE INTENT OF THE BILL IS AS I
THINK YOU'VE CORRECTLY ASSESS.
TO PROVIDE AN OPTIONAL FUNDING
MECHANISM FOR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS. BECAUSE THE
STRUCTURE OF THE STATE. ALLOWS
FOR LOCALS TO CHARGE FIFTY THAT
THEY DEEM. APPROPRIATE TO
ADEQUATE THE AMOUNT OF AT LEAST
THE AMOUNT IN EACH JURISDICTION
IS VERY IS QUITE CONSIDERABLY
AS A RESULT AND BECAUSE SOME OF
THESE JURISDICTIONS HAVE A VERY
VERY SMALL FEE BASED ON THE
WITH A SMALL NUMBER OF. THE
SYSTEM SOME OF THESE
JURISDICTIONS ARE. TO CHARGE A
REASONABLE ENOUGH FEED TO COVER
THEIR COSTS THE FEDERAL AND
STATE REQUIREMENTS. UNDER THS
BILL. LOCAL JURISDICTIONAL
ELECT. TO ARE THE CHARGE THEIR
OWN FEE AS THEY DO NOW. ALL
THEY WILL IF THE STATE ARCH THE
FEET. A SINGLE STATEWIDE THAT
THE- CHARGES ACROSS THE BOARD.
AND THEY WILL. BASICALLY BE
PAID BY THE STATE TO DO THE
WORK THAT THEY HAVE TO DO. SO
IT'S A WIN WIN FOR THE LOCAL.
BECAUSE THEY HAVE AN OPTION OF
EITHER HAVING THE STATE. IMPOSE
THE STATE WIDE B. AND HAVE THE
LOCALS PAID BY THE STATE PUT
DOING THE WORK FOR. THAT DAY
CAN KEEP THE STATUS QUO AND
IT'S A WIN FOR THE STATE
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE TO GEAR
UP AND TAKE OVER THOSE LOCAL
PROGRAMS THAT ARE NOT ABLE TO
PROVIDE THIS SERVICE WITH THE
FEES THAT THEY ARE CURRENTLY
CHARGING. SO WE SEE IS A WIN
WIN AS AN OPTIONAL PROGRAM. IT
ENHANCES AND RETAINS LOCAL
CONTROL. BUT IT ALSO KEEPS THE-
DELEGATION PROCESS FROM THE
STATE WHICH IS SHOWS THAT A
LOCAL JURISDICTION THAT WISHES
TO BE AN LP A- STILL NEEDS THE
NECESSARY REQUIREMENTS. THAT IS
THAT ARE CAPABLE OF PERFORMING
WHAT IT NEEDS TO PERFORM. RIGHT
I LET ME LET ME ASK THE SAME
QUESTION A DIFFERENT WAY I
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE PURPOSE OF
THE BILL IS AND THE MECHANICS-
THAT ARE GOING INTO IT BUT MY
QUESTION IS IF WE ARE TRYING TO
STEER. MORE FUNDING TO. LOCAL
PRIMACY AGENCY WHERE DOES THAT
MONEY COME FROM. MONEY WILL
COME FROM THE BOARD OF POTS OF
MONEY THAT THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD HAS.
AND THE THAT'S WHY INITIALLY
THE WATER AGENCIES WERE
CONCERNED. BECAUSE THE BILL
WOULD COME FROM THE DRINKING
WATERACCOUNT AT THE STATE
WATER RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD.
CURRENTLY MANAGES AND
ADMINISTERS. AT ANY ADDITIONAL
COST WOULD HAVE TO COME FROM
THAT FOLDER ACCOUNT. AND MY
EARLY- WHAT'S THAT THIS BILL IN
OF ITSELF ISN'T. CAUSING AN
INCREASE IN ANY OF THE FEES OR
ANY OF THE AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT
HAS TO BE PAID TO GET THIS JOB
DONE BECAUSE THE LOCALS. CAN
ACTUALLY DO THE WORK LESS THAN
THE STATE. SO IF THE STATE WERE
TO TAKE OVER THOSE CITY EL PA
PROGRAMS. THEY WILL HAVE TO
CHARGE THE SAME OR LACKEY MORE
MONEY. FOR THE STATE TO DO THE
WORK THAT THE LOCALS ARE DOING.
SO THAT'S THE REASON THE LOCAL
THE WATER AGENCIES ARE NOT
NEUTRAL ON THE BILL. AT THE
STATE THE BENEFIT. NXT SAID
SHE'S. BUT BUT AT LEAST GETTING
THE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS THE
CAPACITY TO CONTINUE THAT
PROGRAM. OKAY I UNDERSTAND
THANK YOU FOR THE RESPONSE- I
STILL HAVE A CONCERN HERE THAT-
BECAUSE THERE ISN'T ENOUGH
MONEY COMING OUT IN FEES TO
FUND. A CERTAIN LOCAL PRIVACY
AGENCY THAT PRIVACY AGENT
AGENCY WOULD DELEGATE ITS
AUTHORITY TO THE STATE WATER
BOARD GAME WE DECKED AXIS
THEREBY TO A BROADER POOL OF
FUNDS BUT I DON'T UNDERSTAND
WHERE THOSE FUNDS ARE COMING
FROM AND MY FEAR IS THAT- THE
STATE WATER BOARD LED TO
INCREASE FEES ON OTHER PARTS.
STATE WOULD LEAD LEAD TO FIVE
TWO USERS PAYING INTO A FUND
THAT DIDN'T GET A DIRECT
BENEFIT FROM SO THAT'S MY
CONCERN I'M I'M OKAY ACOSTA-
I'D LIKE TO SUPPORT THE BILL
I'M GONNA STAY OFF IT FOR NOW
JUST BECAUSE I'D LIKE TO GET AN
ANSWER THAT QUESTION I'M SURE
THE THIS BILL AGAIN OR SEE.
WHAT NOW AND THEN. WE GOT.
CONCERT THAT IS. THANK YOU FOR
THAT WHAT WE HAVE OUR ANNIE
GRAY DECENT UPPER THANK YOU
ENOUGH THANK YOU OF ANY OTHER
CAR FROM. DESERVE TO APPROVE.
IT'S BEEN MOVE A SECOND AND
SECOND IS WILL TURN TO AND I
SHOULD HAVE RECOGNIZED A SPARK
HAND IF YOU HAD ANY CLOSING
COMMENTS SO WE CERTAINLY WILL
RECOGNIZE AT THIS TIME NOW
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I'VE-
OKAY. LET'S HAVE A- ALL OF THEM
SIMPLICITY. AB TWO NINE SIX
QUIRK THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
TO THE ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE HOLDEN AYE HOLDEN AYE
MELENDEZ. ARAMBULA OUR CAN I-
CAN I CRISTINA GARCIA. BLOOM HI
BLOOM AYE MATHIS. MURATSUCHI
MERCI GI OR MULTI. OBERNOLTE
NOT VOTING. THAT ONLY HAS FOUR
VOTE OKAY WE WILL PUT THE BILL
ON CALL AND WE WERE TO HAVE
MORE MEMBERS PRESENT TO PROCEED
ON THAT- PARTICULAR MEASURE
WILL NOW TURN TO THE SPA OKAY
HANDLED AS RELATES TO TWENTY
THREE THIRTY THREE WE REALLY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I'M HERE
TO PRESENT AB TWENTY THREE
THIRTY THREE OF A HALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK AB TWENTY
THREE THREE WILL I THINK IT
OVER SITE THAT REQUIRE FOR
LOCAL HEALTH UP. OVERSEE THANK.
WILL TURN IT OVER TO THE AUTHOR
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CORK. A DOCTOR
QUIRKY MAY PERCEIVE BONTA.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAUER QUE HAND
FOR PRESENTING A. B. TWENTY
THREE THIRTY THREE ON MY
BEHALF. AB TWENTY THIRTY THREE
ADDRESSES THE VOLUNTARY CLEANUP
PROGRAM WHICH LOCAL HEALTH
OFFICERS OVERSEE THE
REMEDIATION OF HAZARDOUS WASTE
SITES. YOU MAY RECALL THAT WE
HAVE A SIMILAR BILL A YEAR AGO.
AND I HAD AGREED TO WORK WITH
THE LOCAL HEALTH OFFICERS TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE ALL IN
AGREEMENT BEFORE I. OUTPUT FELL
ONTO THE FLOOR. WE HELD THE
BILL UP WELL WE- GET FURTHER
NEGOTIATIONS THAT'S WHY WE HAVE
THIS NEW BILL NOW THIS BILL
INCLUDES REQUIREMENTS FOR LOCAL
HEALTH OFFICERS AIMED AT MAKING
SURE THEY HAVE THE APPROPRIATE
RESOURCES TO CARRY OUT. THEIR
OVERSIGHT RESPONSIBILITY
INCREASE TRANSPARENCY AND
INFORMATION SHARING WITH THE
PUBLIC IN THE STATE. THE ONE IN
YOUR SCORE MY PRE. ALLSTATE I
COMMITTED TO WORK WITH A LOT
HEALTH BY. TO ADDRESS ANY
OUTSTANDING CONCERNS WITH HIS
BILL MOVES FORWARD THANK YOU I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THE ARRIVE
ABOUT. THANK YOU DOCTOR QUIRK.
WE APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY ON
THIS BILL- PHONE MODERATOR DO
WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY THREE
THIRTY THREE AND THIS WOULD BE
WITNESSES OF NAME. AND POSITION.
IF YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME THAT'S
ONE NINE ZERO. THERE IS NO ONE
QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME OKAY
WAIT I TAKE THAT BACK WE DO
HAVE ONE ONE MOMENT PLEASE
WHILE WE GET THEIR LINE NUMBER.
RIGHT TIME FIFTY LINE FIFTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI GOOD OCT
CARE JUST MULLIN AGAIN WITH THE
LOCAL ENVIRONMENT HEALTH
DIRECTORS AB MANY OF OCT FOLKS
PROVIDE THE SERVICE THAT IS
THAT. THIS PROJECT OF THIS BILL
LOCAL OVERSIGHT WE HAD BEEN
WORKING WITH- DOCTOR QUIRK AND
HE'S COMMITTEE AND OTHER
INTERESTED PARTIES WE'RE NOT
QUITE THERE YET BETWEEN HAPPY
TO WORK WITH HIM A LOCAL HEALTH
AND ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH ARE
CONCERNED. ANY AT I DO WHAT TO
THE PROGRAM. A THE CREW OF TO
NOT THAT OF THESE SMALL THAT TO
BE UP. BUT THE AMENDMENTS MAYES
WERE VERY HELP PEROT. WE NOT
QUITE DAY BUT WE LOOK FORWARD
WORKING WITH A DOCTOR QUIRK AND
HE'S COMMITTEE. IN THIS ISSUE
SIR THANK YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR
INDULGENCE. THANK YOU. AND THAT
WAS THE ONLY ONE IN Q. OKAY
RECRUITED THAT OF. AND ARE
THERE QUESTIONS WILL TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CERVANTES. I THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR IS SO- THE
QUESTION ABOUT THIS BILL ARE WE
TALKING ABOUT A SITUATION WHERE
THIS IS A- A SITUATION WHERE A
OFFICIAL IS ASKING FOR THE
STATE'S HELP OR IS THIS AS A
COERCIVE SITUATION WHERE. THE
DTS HE OR ORIGINAL WATER BOARD
HE IS FORCIBLY TAKING- OF
TAKING CONTROL WHERE THE LOCAL
HEALTH OFFICIALS. QUIRK YES
WE'RE NOT TAKING OUT CONTROL
AWAY THE POINT HERE IS WE
CHANGE WELL FINANCIAL BILL WAS
QUITE DIFFERENT WHAT THIS IS
DOING IS ASKING FOR A REPORT-
AND AGAIN I'M WORKING WITH THE
LOCAL HEALTH OFFICERS THEY
STILL HAVE SOME CONCERNS AS THE
BILL MOVES FORWARD- WILL MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE ALL OF THEIR
CONCERNS THAT. OKAY SO I'M
LOOKING AT A BILL THAT WAS
AMENDED THE SIX SO THAT WAS A
FEW DAYS AGO WAS THAT WAS AT
THE CURRENT VERSION. YEAH OKAY
BECAUSE THIS BILL SAYS. THE
DEPARTMENT OR REGIONAL WATER
CONTROL BOARD SHALL NOT ASSUME
REGULATORY OVERSIGHT OVER A
RELEASE AFTER REMEDIAL ACTION
HAS BEEN OR ENTERED INTO UNLESS
THE DEPARTMENT OR REGIONAL
WATER QUALITY CONTROL BOARD
MAKES ONE OR MORE OF THE
FOLLOWING DETERMINATIONS ONE
THREE MEDIAL SHIN BEING
PROPOSED FOR THE SITE WILL BE
INSUFFICIENT TO ADDRESS THE
CONTAMINATION CAUSED BY THE
RELEASED WAYS. SO MEANS TO ME
THE WHAT THAT'S- WELL HEALTH OF
OUR OFFICIAL HAD TO GO SHE
ADDED. A MITIGATION AGREEMENT
AND THE STATE DISAGREES WITH
THE MEDICATION AGREEMENT THE
STATE CAN TAKE OVER THAT
MITIGATION WHICH I MEAN THAT
SOUNDS VERY COURSE IT TO ME AND
I. AM I MEAN I I'D LOVE TO SEE%
THE FORM THAT THE BILL'S DELTA
MEDLEY HAVE ALL I HAVE TO VOTE
ON IS WHAT'S HERE IN PRINT AND
WHAT'S HERE AND PRINT I THINK
IT IS- IS SUFFICIENTLY
CORROSIVE TOLD. THE THAT I'M
GOOD SUPPORT. SO I HAVE. I
DON'T KNOW COULD ME SOME. ARE
ALSO HOPE. I WILL WORK WITH THE
HELP OFFICERS TO THE POINT
WHERE THEY ARE COMFORTABLE WITH
THE BATH. OKAY IF YOU WANT TO
YOU CAN ASK MISTER ALONE- WHAT
THEY'RE CONTINUING CONTINUING
CONCERNS ARE. ALRIGHT WELL
WE'LL I MEAN THAT'S THAT'S ALL
VOTE ON WHAT'S IN PRINT HERE I
LOOK FORWARD TO SUPPORTING AND
IF WE GET TO A POSITION WHERE
WHERE WHERE I CAN SUPPORT. BUT
ALL I'VE GOT IS WHAT'S IN PRINT
HERE WHICH IS YOU KNOW CANCER
IS CONCERNED ABOUT. BUT I THINK
YOU. HEY CHRIS WROTE A NOTE.
LET ME JUST DOUBLE CHECK WITH
THE PHONE MODERATOR I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT I CLEAR
THE LINE ON ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. AND THAT WOULD BE
JUST THOSE WHO WOULD BE
TESTIFYING GIVING THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION IMPOSITION I JUST
WANT TO DOUBLE CHECK ON THAT.
NO ONE IN THE QUEUE AGAIN IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO. IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. NO ONE DURING UP AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU FOR THAT. OF
WILL ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON THIS
BILL AB TWENTY THREE THIRTY
THREE QUIRK. SECOND IT'S BEEN
MOVED AND SECONDED- THIS IS- DO
PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE OR
CALL THE ROLL. THE BILLS AB
TWENTY THREE THIRTY THREE QUIRK
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. HOLDEN AYE HOLDEN
AYE MELENDEZ ARAMBULA BEAR CAN
HIGH- CAN I CRISTINA GARCIA.
BLOOM BLOOM HI MATT THIS.
MURATSUCHI GI FOR MULTI. HELLO
TINA. THE HOUSE FOUR OF THE
BILL IS ON CALL AND WE WILL. A
MOVIE FIGHTS TO THE NEXT ITEM
WHICH IS ALSO DOCTOR QUIRK A.
B. THIRTY THIRTY NINE- WE WILL
HAVE A MISTER MURATSUCHI A.
CUSTOMER SEARCH YOU CAN PROCEED
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I AM
PRESENTING AB THREE ZERO THREE
NINE ON BEHALF OF CHAIRMAN
DOCTOR QUIRK. THIS BILL IS A
SIMPLE YEAH IT'S IMPORTANT BILL
TO EXTEND THE SUNSET FOR THE
REPLACING REMOVING ARE
UPGRADING UNDERGROUND STORAGE
TANKS PROGRAM. HERE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL IS DOCTOR
QUIRK. DOCTOR QUIRK THANK YOU
MISTER. YES THANK YOU MISTER
MERCY CHEAPER PRETENDING THIS
BILL AB THIRTY THIRTY NINE
EXPAND WHAT ARE YOU ES T. GRANT
ELIGIBILITY TO CERTAIN
APPLICANTS WHO ARE NOT IN
COMPLIANCE WITH WATER QUALITY
OUR AIR QUALITY REQUIREMENTS.
UNDER SPECIFIED CONDITIONS THAT
PROVIDE THE STATE WATER BOARD
WITH ALREADY TO HELP PREVENT
FRAUD WITHIN THE RAFT PROGRAM
AND TO HELP RECOVER MONETARY
LOSSES TO THE REST PROGRAM TO
THE FRAUD IDEAS THIS BILL MAKES
ADDITIONAL MINOR ARE NOT STANCE
OF CHANGES TO THE REST GRANT
AND LOAN PROGRAM. PROFICIENCY
IN CLARIFICATION PURPOSES.
THANK YOU I ASKED WE ARRIVED
ABOUT. THANK YOU DOCTOR QUIRK
OF PHONE MODERATOR WE HAVE ONE
ADDITIONAL PRIMARY WITNESS
THAT'S A KATHY ROTELLO WITH THE
METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA YOU MAY
PROCEED WITH YOUR TESTIMONY. A
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M
HAPPY VIçT HELL OF THE
EXECUTIVE LEGISLATIVE
REPRESENTATIVE WITH
METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICTOF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. WE
WHOLESALE TREATED DRINKING
WATER TO TWENTY NINE MEMBER
AGENCIES TO PROVIDE WATER TO
NINETEEN MILLION CALIFORNIANS
ACROSS SIX COUNTIES IN OUR
SERVICE AREA. AND OUR MISSION
IS TO PROVIDE THE SERVICE AREA
WAS ADEQUATE AND RELIABLE
SUPPLY HIGH QUALITY WATER IN
THE PRESENT AND FUTURE NEEDS
AND THEN THE BAR MENTALLY AND
ECONOMICALLY RESPONSIBLE WAY.
THE REST PROGRAM AS AN
IMPORTANT SOURCE OF GRANT A
LOAN THAT HELP SMALL BUSINESSES
MANAGE TANK LIKE PREVENTION AND
TANK CLEAN UP EFFORTS IN OUR-
UNDERGROUND STORAGE TANK THAT
LEGAL POTENTIAL SOURCE OF
CONTAMINATION IN WATER SUPPLIES
AND THEY CAN LEAVE. HI URBAN
FROM GASOLINE AND OTHER
PETROLEUM BASED PRODUCTS THEY
PRIMARILY AFFECT ON WATER THEY
CAN ALSO AFFECT SURFACE WATERS
AND HYDROLOGIC CONNECTION
BETWEEN THE CONTAMINATED
GROUNDWATER AND SURFACE. THERE
HUNDREDS OF ACTIVE LEAKING
UNDER STORAGE CAKE TO
THROUGHOUT HER SERVICING. READY
OF CASES WE MONO OUR WE GAS FOR
LOCATED WITH AND HOW MILE FROM
THE RATHER. THE COLORADO RIVER
SUPPLIES ABOUT 25% OF THE
REGION'S DRINKING WATER SUPPLY
AND THEREFORE WE TAKE GREAT
CARE TO SAFEGUARD- THIS
RESOURCE WE'VE ALSO RELIED ON
THE VAST PROGRAM- TO CLEAN UP
AFTERWARDS- THE THINKING OF
STORAGE TANKS NEAR LIKE MATTHEW
THAT LIKE SKINNER TWO OF OUR
RESERVOIRS USED TO. STORE AND
THAT WATER THIS BILL WOULD
CONTINUE THE FUNDING PROGRAM
THROUGH JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY
SIX AND WILL HELP SMALL
BUSINESSES CONTINUE THEIR CLEAN
UP EFFORTS TO COMPLY WITH STATE
AND FEDERAL STANDARDS AND IS
THE THIRD PREVENT MEDIC AMONG.
OF CONTAMINATION TO PUBLIC
DRINKING WATER IS ON BEHALF OF
MUCH TALLER WATER DISTRICT. I
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR ALL
SB THIRTY THIRTY NINE AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU WE APPRECIATE
YOUR TO. WILL NOW. INVITE OF
THOSE WITNESSES- THAT ARE GOING
TO PRESENT. JUST PRESENTING
THEIR NAME- AFFILIATION AND
ORGANIZATIONS SO MISTER
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANY PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IN THE QUEUE. I'D
LIKE TO PLACE YOURSELF IN A
QUEUE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE DO HAVE A
COUPLE OF JUST CUED UP PLEASE
ALLOW A FEW MOMENTS REST
TOGETHER LINE NUMBERS. OUR OLD
THREE THAT'S FIVE THREE LINE IS
OPEN. YEAH I JUST WANT TO GAIN
HERE WITH THE LOCAL ENVIRONMENT
HEALTH ADMINISTRATORS- MANY OF
OCT FOLKS PROVIDE AT THE
OVERSIGHT FOR THE CLEAN UP OF
THESE- SITES AND WE'RE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE STILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. AND WILL ALSO
GO TO LINE NUMBER FIFTY TWO
FIVE TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER TERRY MEMBERS
THIS IS STEPHANIE MORE WHILE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA FIELD
AND CONVENIENCE ALLIANCE AND
WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL. I
JUST A QUICK APOLOGY OF FOR NOT
GETTING OUR LETTER IN ON TIME
WE WANT TO THANK THE STAFF AND
THE AUTHOR FOR WORKING WITH US
ON THIS BILL BUT WE ARE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. VERY GOOD
THANK YOU. ARE THE ONLY TWO IN
Q. THANK YOU- WE HAVE NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. I MISSED MODERATOR.
OR PHONE MODERATOR. I DO WE
HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. SB THIRTY THIRTY
NINE. I'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. THERE IS
NO ONE ON THE PHONE LINES
VOICING OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS
ON THIS MATTER. THROW THE NOTED
DO YOU HAVE SOMETHING AGAINST
DOCTOR COURT TODAY. I DON'T TO
CITIES GO AHEAD BUT DOCTOR
QUIRK LOVES HAVING ME ON THIS
COMMITTEE BECAUSE I ALWAYS WAS
SINCE I DON'T. SO I'M I'M OF
SUPPORTER OF THIS BILL ARE ONE
QUESTION I HAVE THOSE IS WHY OF
THE THINGS THIS BILL DOES TO
THE GRANT PROGRAM IS ADDS A
NUMBER OF PROVISIONS. ARE FOR
PENALTIES AND FINES FOR- FOR
VIOLATIONS OF- OF THE PUBLIC
TRUST WHICH I THINK A VERY
APPROPRIATE- THERE IS A SECTION
ON. REFUSAL TO FURNISH
INFORMATION OR FURNISHING FALSE
INFORMATION HERE. AND A PERSON
CAN BE CHARGED- FIND UNDER
THIS. SECTION FOR. ANY OF THE
FOUR REASONS YOU'RE JUST A JUST
HAVE TO ONE IF THE ALLEGED IS
KNOWING WILLFUL INTENTIONAL IF
YOU RECEIVE MATERIAL ECONOMIC
BENEFIT FROM THE ACTION OR IF
THE VIOLATION IS CHRONIC SO MY
QUESTION IS I MEAN IT HAS TO BE
ANY ONE OF THOSE THREE BUT IT
SEEMS TO ME THAT. ANY ARE. A
ANY ONE OF APPLYING FOR GRANT
WOULD HAVE MATERIAL ECONOMIC
BENEFIT BECAUSE IT'S A
FINANCIAL GRANT SO I'M
WONDERING WHAT THAT IS DOING IN
THE SECTION BECAUSE IT SEEMS TO
ME LIKE IT MAKES THE WHOLE
THING MEANINGLESS- I WOULD
SUGGEST THAT THAT. HE CHANGED
TO WHAT IT IS IN OTHER PLACES
IN THE BILL WHICH IS THAT NOW
THAT'S ONE OF THE CONDITIONS
THAT. THE BOARD WOULD CONSIDER
IN SETTING THE AMOUNT OF THE
FINE IS THE DEGREE TO WHICH
THERE WAS MATERIAL ECONOMIC
BENEFIT AND I JUST JUST AT HAT
COMMENT. I WAS NOT REALLY
QUESTION- BUT I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THE BILL THAT JUST A
SUGGESTION. FAIR ENOUGH. LET ME
LET ME SAY I WILL LOOK INTO
THAT JEFF THOROUGHLY. I'LL
STILL HAVE A LITTLE BIT BETTER-
INTRODUCED PREVIOUS QUESTION ON
THE BALLOT TO ALREADY BEEN
HEARD ON WHICH IS THAT THE
STATE WOULD ONLY TAKE OVER IF
THE- A LOCAL HEALTH OFFICERS
DON'T HAVE THE APPROPRIATE
RESOURCES-AND CANNOT EXERCISE
ENFORCEMENT AUTHORITY OVER THE
RESPONSIBLE PARTY- SO. WELL I'M
NOT DEAD AND I DO LOVE HAVING
MISTER OBERNOLTE ON THIS
COMMITTEE. THAT OUR QUESTION
AND WE HAVE TO LOOK INTO THEM
AND I GET REQUESTED TO BE ON IT
AND I'M VERY GLAD TO HEAR. WE
ALL ARE THANK YOU. I WE DO
APPRECIATE THAT WE GIVE A
ADDITIONAL DIFFERENCE
PROVOCATIVE TO THE REALTOR THE
COMMITTEE SO CAN HAVE A LITTLE
BIT MORE LATITUDE THAN MOST SO
WE APPRECIATE THAT ADDITIONAL
INSIGHT FROM THE PREVIOUS BILL-
IS THERE A CLOSE THAT THE-
AUTHOR- RIVERS OF. OKAY THIS
BACKLASH FOR AYE OKAY. OUR
MOTION. IT'S BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED UP WITHOUT OBJECTION
WILL HAVE A ROLL CALL ON THE
MOTION. THE BILL AB THREE ZERO
THREE NINE QUIRK THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO THE ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
HOLDEN AYE HOLDEN AYE MELENDEZ.
ARAMBULA BAUER-KAHAN- CAN I
CRISTINA GARCIA. BLOOM BLOOM
AYE MATHIS. MURATSUCHI HI VERY
FEW GI OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL TI
THE MEASURE HAS FIVE BURGER THE
MEASURES OUT WILL HOLD THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS WILL
NOW TURN TO OUR LAST GO FOR THE
DAY ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SEVEN
SIXTY TWO MURATSUCHI COSMETICS
THE OTHER FOUR THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY TWO IT TOXIC
FREE COSMETICS THAT. WOULD LIKE
TO THANK THE CHAIRMAN DOCTOR
QUIRK WHO IS JOIN ME AS A JOINT
AUTHOR ON THIS BILL LIKE TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF FROM
BOTH E. S. T. M. AS WELL AS THE
HEALTH COMMITTEE FOR- SPENDING
MANY HOURS ON THIS BILL I WANT
TO GIVE SPECIAL THANKS TO PAGE
BROKAW WITH THE S. HIM
COMMITTEE WHO HAS WORKED
ESPECIALLY HARD ON THIS BILL.
THANKS TO ALL OF THE HOURS
SPENT TOO MANY HOURS SPENT
BETWEEN- COMMITTEE STAFF MY
STAFF OF THE SPONSORS AND THE
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL-
WORKING TOGETHER AFTER TWO
YEARS OF WORK THEY COMMITTEE IS
PROPOSING AMENDMENTS TODAY
WHICH I WILL ACCEPT IN THEIR
ENTIRETY. IT IS MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT WITH THESE
AMENDMENTS ALL OPPOSITION WILL
BE REMOVED AND IN I RECEIVED AN
EMAIL INDICATE THAT THE
PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS COUNCIL
WITH EXCEPT THE AMENDMENTS WILL
NOW MOVE TO A SUPPORT HAS BEEN
FOR THE BELL BUT- LET. AS S. O.
WILL BE TWENTY US THE VIRTUALLY
WHAT WE SPEAK FOR HERSELF THIS
BILL WILL BE COSMETICS AND CAL
THAT CA TWELVE TOXIC CHEMICALS
KNOWN AND ESTABLISHED BY
SCIENCE TO CAUSE CANCER
REPRODUCTIVE HARM OR HORMONE
DISRUPTION. IN OVERALL HAVING
THE EFFECT OF SUPPRESSING OUR
IMMUNE SYSTEM WHICH MAKES THIS
BILL NECESSRY DURING THIS
COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC THE
SCIENCE IS CLEAR ON THE HARMFUL
NATURE OF THESE CHEMICALS THESE
CHEMICALS ARE ALREADY BANNED IN
THE EUROPEAN UNION THE INTENT
OF THIS BILL IS THAT THE
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS SHOULD
HAVE THE SAME RIGHT THE SAME
PROTECTIONS. SAME TOPIC FREE
COSMETICS THAT ARE BEING SOLD
IN EUROPE AND OTHER PARTS OF
THE WORLD WITH SIMILAR CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS I HAVE TO I
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL DOCTOR TOP T<c.cyan> WELL IN</c>
EPIDEMIOLOGIST AND CO DIRECTOR
OF THE UC DAVIS ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH SCIENCE CENTER-
COMMUTING GATES SPENT PROGRAM
AND ALSO SUSAN LITTLE- WHAT THE
ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP ONE
OF THE SPONSORS OF THIS BACK.
DOCTOR WHAT TYRONE YOU MAY
PERCEIVE WITH YOUR TESTIMONY.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- I AS- AS THE
REPRESENTATIVE SAID THE FIND A
DISPUTED ACTIVE HARM TO HUMAN
HEALTH CAUSED BY THE TWELVE
CHEMICALS THAT WOULD BE BANNED.
BY THIS BILL AND PAN OF THE
CHEMICALS ARE DIRECTLY LINKED
TO BREAST CANCER AND NINE ARE
LINKED TO A COMPROMISED IMMUNE
SYSTEM. WHICH OF COURSE CAN-
I'LL BE FINISHED ABOUT BUILDING.
AND THE RECOVERY FROM COLBERT
NINETEEN ALL OF THESE BILLS ARE
CURRENTLY BANNED FROM COSMETIC
PRODUCTS SOLD IN THE EUROPEAN
UNION. SHALL DESPITE CLAIMS
THAT A LITTLE BIT OF A TOXIC
CHEMICAL IN A CONSUMER PRODUCT
ID ACOSTA CONCERN THE EVIDENCE
SHOWS THAT EVEN SMALL EXPOSURES
CAN CAUSE HARM. HOPING FETUSES
INFANTS AND CHILDREN. AND NONE
OF US LIVE IN A BUBBLE WE ARE
EXPOSED TO TOXIC CHEMICALS DALY
AND HUMAN LOVE THE CUMULATIVE
EXPOSURES INCREASE THE RISK OF
HARM. SO EVIDENCE IS EMERGING
THAT PEOPLE MOST AFFECTED BY
TOXIC CHEMICAL EXPOSURES ARE
MORE VULNERABLE TO CALL THE
NINETEEN IN PERFECT ABILITY AND
IN RECOVERY IMPORTANTLY NINE OF
THE TWELVE CHEMICALS BANNED BY
THE CELLS ARE LINKED TO
DISRUPTION IN IMMUNE SYSTEM
FUNCTION. WHICH CAN RESULT IN
INFORMATION AND THE BACK
CHRONIC INFLAMMATION IMPEDE
PROPER FUNCTIONING OF THE
IMMUNE SYSTEM. SO I JUST WANT
TO SAY A LITTLE BIT OF WHAT WE
KNOW ABOUT SOMEBODY'S TOXIC
CHEMICALS- DEBTOR THAT THIS
BILL WOULD BAN- STUDY SUBJECT
THE CONNECTION BETWEEN THE P.
FIVE EXPOSURE SUPPRESSED IMMUNE
FUNCTION NORBIT DEVELOPMENTAL
DELAYS AND GREATER RISK OF
AUTOIMMUNE DISEASES.
FORMALDEHYDE IS ANOTHER ONE AND
A KNOWN CARCINOGEN MERCURY IS
BLANK THE DEVELOPMENT OF
REPRODUCTIVE HARM BOTH OF THOSE
LAST TWO NEGATIVE NEGATIVELY
IMPACT IMMUNE SYSTEM. SO THERE
ON THE TRUCK HAMMOCK WHICH-
DEVELOPING BRAIN. AND ALTERED
LEVELS OF FRIDAY KIND WHICH ARE
KEY PLAYERS IN IMMUNE RESPONSE
TO CORONAVIRUS WHICH- HERE
AGAIN. AMONG OTHER HEALTH
IMPACT IMPACT THEIR NEW SYSTEM
DEFENSE THIS AGAIN DEFECTION BY
COLBERT NINETEEN. AND WHO IS
AFFECTED MOST CHILDREN WOMEN OF
CHILDBEARING AGE AND WOMEN OF
COLOR WOMEN OF COLOR OVERLY
EXPOSED TO TOXIC CHEMICALS IN
THE COCKPIT PRODUCTS MARKETED
TO THEM IN FACT- A RECENT AND I
EIGHT STUDY. NATIONAL INSTITUTE
OF ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
SCIENCES SHOW THAT BLACK WOMEN
WHO FREQUENTLY DYE THEIR HAIR
FACE OF 60% INCREASED RISK OF
BREAST CANCER APPALLING BECAUSE
WE AS A BLACK WOMAN MYSELF
ALREADY FACE THE HIGHEST
MORTALITY RATE FROM BREAST
CANCER. ENDING YOUR U. S.
RACIAL ETHNIC GROUP. SO KNOW IN
A WOMEN WILL EXPERIENCE BREAST
CANCER IN THEIR LIFETIME AND
THIS IMPORTANT BILL TAKES US
ONE STEP CLOSER TO PREVENTING
BREAST CANCER. BY REMOVING A
MAJOR SOURCE OF ONGOING
EXPOSURE TO SOME OF THE MOST
TOXIC CHEMICALS ON THE PLANET.
I'M FINANCES AS A WOMAN OF
COLOR AND THE MOTHER OF THREE
DAUGHTERS. WE FACING THE
STATISTICAL PROBABILITY THAT
OUR RISK OF BREAST CANCER COULD
BE INCREASED SIMPLY BECAUSE OF
OUR PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS. I'M
HERE TODAY TO TELL YOU THAT
SIMPLY NOT OKAY. SPECIALLY
SINCE THEY FOR ALTERNATIVE TO
THESE CHEMICALS EXIST. AND THE
COMPANIES SELLING THESE
PRODUCTS HERE IN THE U. S.
THEY'RE SELLING THE SAME
PRODUCT WITHOUT THE TOXIC
CHEMICALS IN EUROPE EXCUSE ME
DOCTOR THOUGH THANKS SO MUCH.
OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH NOW.
RIGHT APPRECIATE ABLE TO. GET
THE BY BY PHONE THANK YOU WE
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY A
STUDENTS IS A LITTLE WITH
ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP YOU
MAY PROCEED WITH YOUR TESTIMONY.
VERY MUCH- I'M SUSAN LITTLE
WITH THE ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING
GROUP. CAN YOU HEAR ME WE CAN
SEE YOU WE CAN HEAR YOU OKAY
THANK YOU THIS IS A LITTLE WHAT
THE ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP
EWG IS PLEASED TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO JOIN WITH BLACK
WOMEN FOR WELLNESS CALPERS AND
BREAST CANCER PREVENTION
PARTNERS IN CO SPONSORING THIS
BILL AND WE ALL THINK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MERCY JEEPERS HARD WORK.
TO GET US HERE. WHEN OUR
ORGANIZATIONS COMPARED THE
NOMINAL COSMETICS REGULATION IN
THE UNITED STATES THE ROBUST
SAFETY REQUIREMENTS FOR
COSMETICS. SOLD IN THE EUROPEAN
UNION. WE WERE SURPRISED BY THE
DISPARITY. THE FOOD AND DRUG
ADMINISTRATION ONLY BANDS OR
RESTRICTS ELEVEN INGREDIENTS
FROM HOUSTON US COSMETICS. AND
HAS VERY LITTLE AUTHORITY TO
PROTECT CONSUMERS OTHERWISE.
THE E. YOU ON THE OTHER HAND
PROHIBITS THE USE OF THIRTEEN
HUNDRED INGREDIENTS. AND
FURTHER RESTRICT SEVERAL
HUNDRED MORE OVERALL MORE THAN
FORTY NATIONS HAVE TAKEN STEPS
TO BAN INGREDIENTS. OF CONCERN
FROM THESE VERY THESE EVERYDAY
PRODUCTS. CALIFORNIANS DESERVE
BETTER AND SHOULD BE CONFIDENT
THAT THEIR PRODUCTS THEY RUB ON
THEIR SKIN EACH DAY. DON'T
CONTAIN THE TWELVE HARMFUL
CHEMICALS LISTED IN THIS BILL.
PLEASE SUPPORT AB TWENTY SEVEN
SIXTY TWO THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT YOU
HAD A LIST OF ME TO USE THAT
YOU WANTED TO READ AND TO THE
INTO THE RECORD. ALL FROM THE
AMONG THE PUBLIC HEALTH
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
ORGANIZATIONS AMERICAN COLLEGE
OF OBSTETRICIANS AND
GYNECOLOGISTS BLACK WOMEN FOR
WELLNESS BREAST CANCER OPTION
BREAST CANCER PREVENTION
PARTNERS A CO SPONSOR BREAST
CANCER OVER TIME COALITION FOR
CLEAN AIR CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA
HEALTH COALITION ADVOCACY
PHYSICIANS FOR SOCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY OF SAN FRANCISCO
RESPONSIBILITY OF LOS ANGELES
CALPERS ANOTHER CO SPONSOR
CONSUMR FEDERATION OF A
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA PRODUCT
STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL NATIONAL
STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL ACTION
COUNCIL LESS PER CONSIDER
TURNING OF CALIFORNIA. OF
CALIFORNIA. OTHER ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH AND JUSTICE
ORGANIZATIONS ALASKA COMMUNITY
ACTION ON TOXICS CALIFORNIA
HEALTHY NELSON SO LONG
COLLABORATIVE. CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION VOTERS CENTER FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH CHANGE
CLEAN WATER ACTION ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENT USA
ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP CO
SPONSORS OURSELVES. SCIENCE IN
THE ENVIRONMENT HEALTH NETWORK
SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA SMART
OAKLAND SEVENTH GENERATION
ADVISORS WOMEN'S VOICES FOR THE
EARTH RIGHT MAYBE O
LEGISLATION CALIFORNIA ONE OF
THE FAKE ORGANIZATIONS AND THE
BEAUTY ORGANIZATIONS AND OTHER
BUSINESSES. BADGER BODY CARE
BEAUTY COUNTER BIO SONGS
CALIFORNIA BABY EARTH MAMA ECO
FUNDS SUSTAINABLE SLOG EIGHTY
TWO DEGREES ESSENTIAL OILS ECO.
IN OUR SON IS AT. JUST THE BEDS
OZ NATURALS SEVENTH GENERATION
SCAN AL ROUTE SAN FRANCISCO AND
A HUNDRED SAID PERCENT HERE
THANK YOU THANK YOU WE
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY- WE
WILL NOW- ASK THE PHONE
MODERATOR TO. SEE IF THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY TWO NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION. THANK
YOU ONCE AGAIN IF YOU'D LIKE TO
SPEAK AND SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
WE DO HAVE. COUPLE THAT ARE
QUEUING UP HERE WE'LL GO TO
LINE NUMBER FORTY EIGHT FOUR
EIGHT. THEY JUST TOOK
THEMSELVES OUT OF Q. SO WE'LL
GO TO LINE FORTY SEVEN FIVE
FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
LINE FORTY SEVEN YOU MAY SPEAK.
JERRY NO RESPONSE FROM THAT
LINE IT LOOKS LIKE LINE FORTY
EIGHT HAS RE QUEUED WILL GO
BACK TO LINE NUMBER FORTY EIGHT.
I CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES WE CAN
YES YOUR LINE IS OPEN OKAY
RIGHT YOU KNOW HOW TO READ FROM
A VOICE BETRAYED ADVOCACY OUT
WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF THE MOUTH.
THANK YOU. AND LOOKS LIKE LINE
FORTY SEVEN IS RE QUEUED LET'S
SEE IF THERE'S TAKEN A HOLD OFF
A MUTE LINE FORTY SEVEN YOU'RE
OPEN. DANIEL COULD HEAR THEM
BEHALF OF THE CONSUMER
FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU ARE THE ONLY
TWO LINES IN Q. THANK YOU
APPRECIATE THAT- WE HAVE TWO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION A LESS
AMENDED BOTH ARE TESTIFYING THE
OTHER WITH THIS VIDEO
CONFERENCE ROOM. OF THE FIRST
WOULD BE MANDY LEE ON BEHALF OF
THE PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS
COUNCIL YOU MAY PROCEED WITH
YOUR TESTIMONY. YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS IMMEDIATELY
ON BEHALF OF THE PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS COUNSEL REPRESENTING
OVER SIX HUNDRED SMALL MEDIUM
LARGE COMPANIES. HUNDRED OF
WHICH EITHER CALL CALIFORNIA
HOME OR HAVE A PRESENCE IN IT-
I ALSO WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHORS AND THE SPONSORS. AND A
SPECIAL SHOUT OUT TO- THE STM
COMMITTEE CONSULTANT PAGE BROKE
OFF FOR HER VERY HARD WORK IN
THE LAST- SEVERAL DAYS MANY
MANY HOURS MANY EMAIL
EXCHANGES. AND THE LIKE-
LEADING UP TO THIS POINT- WHERE
WE FEEL LIKE WHERE WE ARE WHERE
WE NEED TO BE WITH THE SPELL.
AND WITH THE AUTHOR ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS PC PC
IS PLEASE NOT ONLY TO MOVE OUR
OPPOSITION BUT ALSO TO SUPPORT
EIGHT TWO. SEVEN SIX TWO. THE
PRIMARY GOAL JUST MUCH BETTER
LINE WITH THE REGULATE IN THE
U. I. A COMP THIS. WITHOUT
COSTS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH OR THIS INDUSTRY
OR CONSUMERS. NEEDLESS TO SAY
EVERY DOLLAR SPENT ON PUBLIC
HEALTH TODAY AND IN THE FUTURE
NEEDS TO BE PRIORITIZED
APPROPRIATELY. THIS AGREEMENT A
SIGNIFICANT AND THAT CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS WILL BE ASSURED THAT
COSMETICS AND PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS THEY PURCHASE NOT ONLY
MEET THE STANDARDS OF THE
STATE. INCLUDING THOSE SET
FORTH BY PROPOSITION SIXTY FIVE
THEIR RESOURCES BOARD GREEN
CHEMISTRY CALIFORNIA FOOD DRUG
AND COSMETIC ACT ALONG WITH
THOSE FTA FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS.
BUT NOW THE ADDED LAYER OF
MEETING THE E. YOU STAND. AB
TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY TWO IS A
PRODUCT OF A- MULTI YEAR
DIALOGUE THAT ALTERNATELY CAME
TOGETHER BECAUSE OF TRUE
COLLABORATION WITH INDUSTRY.
AND IT'S OUR HOPE THAT OUR
SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY SEVEN
SIXTY FIVE SIGNAL SEVERAL
THINGS NUMBER ONE. THAT OUR
INDUSTRY CAN AND DOES SUPPORT
SENSIBLE SOLUTIONS AND NUMBER
TWO THAT WE ARE WILLING TO HOLD
OURSELVES TO HIGHER LEVELS OF
HEALTH AND SAFETY. BUT IT HAS
TO BE GROUNDED IN SCIENCE AND
DATA. IT ALSO IT'S ALSO OUR
HOPE THAT OUR SUPPORT SIGNALS
RESPECT FOR THIS LANDMARK.
LEGISLATION THIS DEAL IF YOU
WELL BECAUSE- OUR INDUSTRY
DESPERATELY NEEDS SHOW SHORT
AND LONG TERM REGULATORY
CERTAINTY SB RECOVER FROM THE
ECONOMIC IMPACTS OF COVERT
NINETEEN. AS WAS ELOQUENTLY
OUTLINED IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS. THIS WAS FOUNDATIONAL
AND US TO DETERMINING THAT WE
COULD SUPPORT THE SPELL. WE
REALLY SEE THIS AS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SHIFT THE
NARRATIVE- WITH RESPECT TO OUR
INDUSTRY WE ARE NOT OPERATING
IN THE WILD WILD WEST ACCORDING
TO SOME. WE DON'T MAKE PRODUCTS
AT HER COST CONSUMERS WE
SUPPORT SCIENCE AND
SENSIBILITY. OUR INDUSTRY MAKES
PRODUCTS THAT HELP CONSUMERS ON
THE ROAD TO HELL. WE COMPLY
WITH REGULAR A STATE AND
FEDERAL LAWS WITH RESPECT TO
SAFETY. AND HONESTLY SPEAKING
THE REAL PUBLIC HEALTH THE REST
PUBLIC HEALTH RISK LIES WITH A
LIST OF PRODUCTS MADE BY WAY OF
THE BLACK MARKET AND THE
LEGITIMATE INDUSTRY CAN NO
LONGER TAKE THE BRUNT FOR THE
LIST OF MARKET. WE CANNOT
COMPLETE THESE TWO. SO MISTER
CHAIRMAN BURSTING YOU FOR YOUR
INDULGENCE AND WE ARE PLEASED
TO SPEND OUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU
WE APPRECIATE THE HARD WORK
THAT ALL OF YOU PUT INTO THIS.
I WILL NOW TURN TO DANKA PAKI
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION AND JOHNSON AND
JOHNSON. YOU MAY PROCEED WITH
YOUR TESTIMONY. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS DON CAP KEEP WITH MCCUE
CAP CAN ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS
AND TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION SEEM
TO A GREATLY APPRECIATES THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR THE COMMITTEE CHAIR. AND
COMMITTEE STAFF IN PARTICULAR
PAGE BROKAW ON GETTING TO THE
PLACE WE'RE SEEM TA IS NOW ABLE
TO REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION AND
MOVE TO A NEUTRAL POSITION. IT
IS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT THAT
SEEM TO MEMBERS A CHEAP THE BAD
CRITICAL CHANGES SPECIFICALLY
TO ENSURE THE PROVISIONS OF AB
TWO SEVEN SIX TO. ALIGN WITH
THE EUROPEAN UNION PARTICULARLY
AS IT RELATES TO FOCUS ON
INTENTIONALLY ADDED INGREDIENTS
UNDERSTANDING OF THE NEED TO
CONSIDER WHAT MAYBE
TECHNOLOGICALLY. UNAVOIDABLE
TREES CONTAMINANTS AND TO FOCUS
ON PROHIBITING GRADIENTS RATHER
THAN DEMAND A PRODUCT AT ALL
TREATED. WITH THE AUTHORS
ACCEPTANCE OF THESE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND TO ADDRESS THESE
CONCERNS SEEM TO USE PLEASE
REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION IS NOW
NEUTRAL ON AB. TWO SEVEN SIX
TWO THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
VERY MUCH WE'RE THE HARD WORK
THAT. YOUR ORGANIZATION
YOURSELF OF PUT INTO THIS AND
IT'S CONFIRMING THE REMOVAL OF
OPPOSITION- FROM THIS BILL- BY
THE PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS
COUNCIL. AND THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION OF WE ARE.
RECOGNIZING ALL OF THE GOOD
WORK AND I WOULD ON BEHALF OF
DOCTOR QUIRK LIKE TO THANK ALL
OF THE STAKEHOLDERS THE AUTHOR.
AND ARE COMMITTEE MEMBERS WHO
HAVE WORKED INCREDIBLY HARD TO
GET THIS BILL TO WHERE IT IS
TODAY. IT'S BEEN A YEAR AND A
HALF OF WORKING ON THIS POLICY
IN THE BILL. AS THE COMMITTEE
PROCESSES. TO A BANDIT TODAY.
REFLECTS THE CUMULATIVE EFFORTS
OF A LOT OF INDIVIDUALS AND
ORGANIZATIONS TO FIND CONSENSUS.
THIS BILL WILL ADDRESS PROBLEMS
RAISED BY THE AUTHOR AND THE
SPONSORS ABOUT COSMETICS SAFETY
AND BY FOLLOWING THE E. U.'S
REGULATORY LEAD WILL JOIN AN
INTERNATIONAL STANDARD VERIFIED
BY REPUTABLE SCIENCE. FOR
COSMETICS SOLD IN CALIFORNIA. I
AM PROUD THAT THIS COMMITTEE.
AND THE LEADERSHIP OF DR QUIRK
IS GUIDED BY THE BEST SCIENCE
TO SAY PUBLIC POLICY IN
CALIFORNIA AND WE WILL CONTINUE
TO USE THAT STANDARD. ON OUR
FUTURE BILLS. THANK YOU A
CUSTOMER SEARCHING THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. YEAH IT'S BEEN
MOVED AND SECONDED I'D LIKE TO.
I HAVE THE PHONE MODERATOR-
DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT THERE
IS ANY WITNESSES ONLINE I WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
OF AB TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY TWO.
AND THIS WOULD JUST BE NAME
AFFILIATION AND THEIR POSITION.
WE DO HAVE A COUPLE THAT HAVE
ALREADY CUED UP I WILL GO TO
THOSE LINES BUT REMIND THE
OTHERS THAT THEY CAN QUEUE UP
BY PRESSING ONE THEN ZERO WE
WILL GO TO LINE NUMBER FORTY
SIX THAT'S FOUR SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THE AFTERNOON CHAIR ME
MEMBERS AT RUNNING THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE.
ECHOING ALL THE COMMENTS. THANK
YOU EVERYONE. ALL STAKEHOLDERS
AND DOCTORS FOR ALL THE WORK
INCLUDING. AND AGE BROKE OFF
WITH THE CHANGES THAT. OF
COMMERCE. IF YOU WOULD BE THE
MAN AT THE CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
WILL BE MOVING TO A NEUTRAL
POSITION. THAT AGAIN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU WILL NOT A
LINE EIGHTEEN THAT'S ONE EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON NICOLE CAN UNITS
REPRESENTING THE FRAGRANCE
CREATORS ASSOCIATION- WE ARE
ALSO REMOVING OPPOSITION- WITH
THESE AMENDMENTS IN
APPRECIATION EVERYONE HARD WORK
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ANDWE'LL
GO TO LINE NUMBER FIFTY FOUR
THAT'S FIVE FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN GOOD AFTERNOON TIM SHIFTED
WITH THE AMERICAN CHEMISTRY
COUNCIL- ALSO REMOVING-
OPPOSITION APPRECIATE
EVERYONE'S HARD WORK ON THIS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND WE HAVE ONE MORE FOR
QUEUING UP. LINE THIRTY FIVE
THREE FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE RAINY POLLOCK
ON BEHALF OF AMWAY AND BASED ON
AMENDMENTS WE ALSO WILL BE
REMOVING OUR OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. AB SIGNIFIES THE END OF
THE QUEUE. THANK YOU WILL BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ARE
THERE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
ON BEHALF OF. A MEMBER OF THE
COMMITTEE. YES GARCIA I JUST
WANT TO THANK THE- EITHER FOR
HIS HARD WORK OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS EIGHT I DO APPRECIATE
THAT AND I DO WANT TO RECOGNIZE
THAT. I AND A LOT OF US AND
THAT'S A LOT ALONG THE WAY AND
SO THANK YOU FOR THAT THANK YOU.
THE CITY NO OTHER COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE MISS MURATSUCHI
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. I
WOULD LIKE TO GIVE A- THANKS TO
THE NOT ONLY THE SPONSORS- BUT
ALSO THE OPPONENTS. I WANT TO
GIVE SPECIAL THANKS TO THE
PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS COUNSEL.
FOR NOT ONLY. REMOVING THEIR
OPPOSITION BUT TO MOVE TO A
POSITION OF SUPPORT. I THINK
THIS IS A GREAT EXAMPLE OF. HOW
WELL WE CAN. ALL WORK TOGETHER
TO ACHIEVE WHAT WE ALL WANT
WHICH IS. SAFE AND TOXIC FREE
SPENDING WITH I HAD. I'VE GOT A
MOTION SIR. THANK YOU. THEY
WERE THE COMMITTEE SECRETARY
ONE UNIT. OKAY THIS IS THEIR
PASSES A MINUTE TO THE ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE. AB TWO SEVEN
SIX TWO MURATSUCHI HI AT THAT.
INSTINCTIVE THE MOTION IS DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE HOLDEN
AYE HOLDEN AYE MELENDEZ. MULLIN
IS NOT VOTING. A REGULAR A
REGULAR I CAN CAN HI CRISTINA
GARCIA CRISTINA GARCIA HI BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE MATHIS AT THIS I.
MURATSUCHI HI THERE CITY I
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE NOT VOTING.
THAT MEASURE HAS SEVEN ABOUT.
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU LET'S MOVE TO THE TOP OF
THE FILE- WILL MAKE HER WAY
pTHROUGH TO HAVE MEMBERS OUT ON.
IF THEY HAVE NOT VOTED ON ANY
OF THESE MEASURES. WE WILL
BEGIN WITH THE CONSENT CALENDAR
WE HAD TO REDO OF ADULTS OKAY
SO CURRENT STILL STANDS AT SIX
NOTHING WITH THAT CHAIR VOTING
AYE MELENDEZ MELENDEZ AYE
ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA HI MATHIS
MATHIS I. IS NINE VOTES. THE
NEXT MEASURE IS AB TWO EIGHT
EIGHT TWO TWO THE MOTION IS DO
PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE THE CURRENT VOTE IS
FIVE ZERO TWO CHAIR VOTING HI.
MELENDEZ MELENDEZ I. BLOOM HI
BLOOM AYE MATHIS. MATHIS NOT
VOTING. AND OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE NOT VOTING. THAT IS
SEVEN ZERO. THE BILL HAS
ALREADY UP. THE NEXT MEASURES
AB NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE AS
SUMMER CRISTINA GARCIA THE
MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
THE CURRENT VOTE IS. SIX
NOTHING- MELINDA'S MELENDEZ NO
MATHIS. MATHIS NOT VOTING. SEE
MY MATH MIGHT BE OFF ON. SIX TO
ONE. BILLS OUT. THE NEXT
MEASURES AB TWO TWO NINE SIX
QUIRK THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WE
CURRENTLY HAVE. FOR AYE VOTES
AND WITH THE CHAIR VOTING AYE
MELENDEZ MULLIN THERE'S NO.
BETTER CAN. TWO TWO NINE SIX.
WHERE CAN I A WEEK A REGULAR A
REGULAR I. CRISTINA GARCIA
CRISTINA GARCIA HI MATHIS.
MATHIS NOT VOTING. SIXTY ONE
THE BILL ITSELF. THE NEXT
MEASURES EIGHTY TWO THREE THREE
THREE QUIRK THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
CURRENTLY FOR AYE VOTES ONE NO
VOTE THAT THE CHAIR VOTING AYE
MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ AYE AYE.
ARAMBULA A REGULAR I. CRISTINA
GARCIA CRISTINA GARCIA HI MATT
THIS. YES SIR. MATHIS NO.
MEASURES SEVENTY TWO. AND THE
LAST MEASURES AB THREE ZERO
THREE NINE QUIRK THE MOTION IS
TO PASSED THE ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
CURRENTLY. FIVE AYE VOTES FOR
THE CHAIR VOTING AYE MELENDEZ
MELENDEZ HI A REGULAR. A
REGULAR I CRISTINA GARCIA
CRISTINA GARCIA HI MATT THIS.
AT THIS I THE HAS NINE VOTES.
IN. LET ME JUST SAY THAT- FOR
THE RECORD THAT TWENTY THREE
THIRTY THREE WASON CALL AND IT
IS NOW OFF AND IT'S CLEAR
COMMITTEE AND THE CITY WOULD BE
THE CASE FOR THE TWO NINETY SIX
WAS ON CALL LOOK AT THE CALL
EDITORS REQUIRED RECEIVE THE
REQUIRED ROADS. YES. NO NO MORE
BILLS ON CALL. OKAY EVERYBODY'S
ON RECORD THEN WE- I WANT TO
THANK THE STAFF I WANT TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE FOR THEIR
ASSISTANCE IN ALLOWING US TO
MOVE TO THIS BILL THROUGH THIS-
MEETING HOPEFULLY AS SEAMLESSLY
AS POSSIBLE WE RETURNED.